sure so
you know i moved to orlando in 2004 to
go to college
um after college i started working a
real estate company
now we were doing really well and then i
saw an opportunity
i was actually playing poker one day and
this guy slid a little packet across the
day we said what is this
if you can figure out what this is we
can make a lot of money and
what do you mean he was like trying it
and could be no he actually owned head
shops
and so they sold these products in their
stores
and he didn't understand he didn't
really know what they were putting on
the damiana
and and marshmallow the loose leaf that
was making people high it was given at
the time jwh
18 gave it literally was like a weed
high so
it wasn't crazy now when you hear uh k2
like run for the hills because that
stuff is making people fall up on the
floor
dangerous stuff and i've seen it with my
own eyes not cool
but back back then before they kept
modifying you know what they do is they
move it like one carbon molecule to the
left or
whatever then they just call it
something else and now they've got all
kinds of chemicals i don't even know
what they're currently selling the
cannabinoids
but they don't produce a cannabis like i
now they're like more like a tryptamine
or something like it's like it's
literally like they went into another
universe
so yeah not cannabis
um so that's what you were trying to
basically do is just mimic
cannabis because because it obviously
wasn't legal back right
so you know they had a line that was
that was our bread and butter at the
head shops when it was legal when they
could buy this stuff
it was never scheduled see it wasn't
scheduled at the time
it was covered under the federal analog
act though in the federal
analog act see what you in the feds you
have the controlled substances act
which can which controls everything
category one through four or whatever
of all of the listed controlled
substances but then they've also got
what's called the federal analog act the
federal analog act states that any
substance that produces a similar or
like
mind altering effect they can charge you
with the nearest related substance
so even though that's not the substance
you have that's what they're going to
charge you with
because it produces a similar effect
when you're when you were playing poker
and your buddies slid this little baggie
of
k2 to you what happened after that
so i sent it to a lab in texas i had it
analyzed and it came back as jwh
and jwh is a it's an analog it's a can
it's a synthetic cannabinoid
at the time it was not scheduled um and
then i started looking for suppliers
and in china i found a whole a whole
host of suppliers i ended up going with
a company called uh
kansotech excuse me kanzotek private
limited in
jamsu china and i was getting this stuff
for like
1200 bucks a kilogram wait wait how how
do you go
how do you i feel like you you're
progressing down this path way too fast
like
what were you doing prior to this how
are you making money what were you doing
i was running a property management
company i was making a buck 20 a year i
was doing good
uh you know i have a college degree i
was doing good but
at the time like i see a way to make
money and the entrepreneur for me is
just like
figure out how to do it i wasn't
thinking about the repercussions i
wasn't thinking about who it might hurt
i wasn't thinking about
the consequences positive or negative i
was just thinking about
how much money can we make and how fast
you knew that you could sell this stuff
to head shops
right and people that were producing the
products selling it to head shops like i
have a buddy in the fort lauderdale area
won't say any names but
was you know selling millions of units
so you knew somebody who's already doing
it and very large you wanted to
duplicate what he was doing
i didn't just want to duplicate it i
wanted to get myself in the middle
between me and the people that were
producing it and i wanted to become the
largest importer
period i wanted to find a way to
position myself
where we were bringing the largest
amount possible into the country and
reselling it to people who were
producing the products
and i was pretty successful at doing
that i negotiated a consignment
relationship we were bringing in
hundreds of kilos a month
so um a very large quantity of this
stuff
so okay so so um once you
how did you find somebody in china with
and how did you know
what you were looking for google you
just google it you just googled the
ingredients of this stuff and then you
found out the biggest manufacturer
right so i searched the chemical when i
found out what the chemical was and i
searched it
and i started looking for suppliers and
i saw like i think read it i just read
and read and read and i found some
people that said hey you can order from
this lab you can order from this lab
and after you found the company in china
that you want to do business with
how much were you buying with them what
kind of deal did you do with them so it
started slow
i ordered a key i think i ordered a
kilogram probably maybe 500 grams
how much was that uh a thousand bucks
oh wow okay it wasn't much the kilo the
i think the kilogram we were paying 1500
for but when i bought 100 of them
i would get 1200 okay i think the
cheapest way we got it was like 1100.
okay so you know and the chemicals
quickly change so
china isn't like the united states in
the united states like we find out like
something's going to be scheduled
or something's you know undergoing
testing right now they're determining
whether or not they're going to bring it
on the schedule how it's going to be
scheduled what the potency is
the dea toxicology report comes back and
says it's like
equivalent to this amount of marijuana
or whatever it's pretty crazy how they
do that actually but um
in china it's black and white it's like
it's either illegal or it's not
there's no gray area and they give their
manufacturers a heads up they're like
look
whatever you got of this chemical
liquidate it get rid of it
or destroy it because after this date
which is i think it's usually like
january 1st
if you get caught with it you're going
to present so
you know their their suppliers in china
know that
and they work around it so when it when
something's coming up they know it's
going to be scheduled
they just change the chemical a little
bit where it
still produces a similar effect but now
it's technically
legally a different chemical so or
chemically a different
chemical so uh so that's how they skirt
the wall there
and you know is it really skirting the
law i don't know i think
they just haven't thought it through as
much as we have in the united states
if it produces a similar like
mind-altering effect doesn't matter if
it's illegal or not
if you get caught with that substance
you're going to prison okay so
very different so what was the first
substance that you were buying jwh-18
jwh-18 and you're buying this for like
1100 bucks a kilo yep
15 15 and then it got cheaper and then
what you started selling it to who
started selling it to people who are
reducing producing the products okay and
started producing our own brand called
kush we actually had the first menthol
variety called cush ice
and we were selling thousands tens of
thousands of units so
sold them little plastic vials all over
florida and
uh they got it's crazy how much how we
sold them for a dollar a piece on
consignment
and one gram of pure jwh-18
would produce 10 grams of smokable
product
so pretty how much came in a little vial
one gram one gram one gram a dollar a
piece
well we sold it for a dollar a piece the
stores are selling it for
twenty bucks twenty five dollars so
they're making a crazy
crazy well see kate that's how we got in
by lowballing people
k2 is charging five six dollars a unit
and we're selling it for a dollar on
consignment so we're to check net 30.
we're not getting paid the day they get
it we're getting paid 30 days from then
so how long did it take before you
started making like crazy money uh
about a year six months to a year six
months we were making
three to five thousand a month wasn't
crazy after a year we were making like
man we had 20 000 days it was i remember
one day
we did almost 100 grand and i remember
thinking like wow
like we made it this is the biggest
payday i've ever
had and the amount of money that was
coming in it was impossible to say no
and i knew that we were playing with
fire
at that point i already knew it was like
a feeling man your intuition will never
lie to you
and the problem is all these temptations
you know what i mean the lifestyle
being able to fly to vegas and rent
helicopters and
do whatever not think about the price
tag that
is so alluring that when you're caught
in the mix
or at least i can use i statements when
i was caught in the mix
i couldn't say no you know and now
having been through what i've been
through it's a totally different story
of course i would say no
but um so you say a hundred thousand
dollar days is that like
like revenue or is that profit revenue
revenue
yeah yeah that's insane that's a crazy
amount of money yeah we're paying
one and how old were you 25
26 wow pretty crazy
you